burke
is you darvish
34 year old making his ninth start back
to back start against these rocks trevor
story 267 to begin the night four homers
and 21 runs batted in
swinging a miss and story strikes out
first k of the night for you darvish two
down there's that 97 i was talking about
and it's showing it early
for schemer in
really tough to catch up to eight starts
this year four and three record but a
very fine 293 earned run average and
three quarters of his starts have come
at coors field so tren grisham leading
it off here for the friars in the bottom
of the first inning 2-1
and this is over this shift into right
center field
the gapper as
hampson has to go all the way back to
the wall to get it heading for third is
grisham the throw not in time a triple
for trent grisham starts the bottom of
the first inning for the padres well one
of the most exciting places baseball is
the triple this ball just leaks down the
middle of the plate and grisham is all
over it look at that level swing short
compact rifles it to the gap
he's got three on his mind
right there
put the head down he doesn't need any
help from bobby dickerson
at third with nobody out here's manny
machado
in the air to deep left field tapia
going back at the wall
leaps and can't get it it's gone
two-run home run for manny machado
padres take a two nothing lead in the
first inning what a start
the hanging breaking ball cuidado
you hanging oh he will bang him
and a great effort not enough for tapia
how close was it what a great effort by
the rockies left fielder
corner worth that second base two down
here in the padres first inning well
here is jerickson pro far activated just
before the ball game a payoff pitch
and it's chopped to first base back is
joe gonna need gray low toss and he
drops the baseball
run scores
in the back door from third is
crawlerworth and the padres take a
three-nothing lead
the low throw
from connor joe gray
had it for a moment but it then came out
of the glove
and ruled safe at first base is jericho
profar see if the ball is in his glove
when he touches the back and then when
he leaves the bag he loses it
fawn glove
touches the bag
and then loses it how they gonna rule
that i think he's gonna be out i think
so too
safe at first base wow
padres take a three-nothing lead
so trevor story leading off in the
fourth inning against udarvish
and this is line to laughs good to see
trevor
get a knock
so a leadoff single for story in the
fourth
in front of ryan mcmahon this location
here's fly ball shallow left incoming
fam
and tommy fan makes the catch
he was battling the light back i think
he came in
kind of shading his eyes with his hand
and then makes the catch before it hits
the grass
to on nobody out and ha sung kim coming
up for the padres
line caught and the flip to second is
late
trevor story on a good catch moving
towards the bag at second
reels in the line drive for out number
one he tried to turn it into two two on
one away and here is victor curitini
on three and two they do not run and the
pitch is lined to left field tapia
coming over he won't get there it's
gonna roll all the way to the corner
o'grady has scored profar's on his way
tarantini into second that is a two-run
double and a five-nothing cadre lead
here in the fourth caratini on this one
the high breaking ball staying on it
taking it exactly where it's pitched
that is pretty
john gray does not have the good feel
for that breaking ball
two rbi double for
victor caratini hail to the victim
padres have the lead leadoff hit her on
for the rockies in the fifth and dom
nunez the catcher
and a swing and a miss another throw
down to first down this one bounce down
there
as nunez strikes out for the second time
tonight
six strikeouts now for darvish one down
and he strikes out
so that is seven strikeouts and the
second time gray has struck out in the
game tonight
no two pitch coming up to tapia
swinging a miss and darvish strikes out
the side runner in third in pro far and
nobody out the padres sixth inning
[Applause]
to left and a base hit for kim from
third comes profar padres lead at six
nothing
[Applause]
he got his slider
caught it out front
[Applause]
nice level swing hits this ball on the
line
ha sung kim is awesome kim
manny machado likes it who does it now
you darvish
lines one down the left field line it's
a fair ball rattles around in the corner
you darvish gets his first hit in the
padres uniform and it's a double
the
advantage
not anymore
runners on the corners two outs and
manny machado coming up already
ground ball towards shortstop story has
it go through him
darvish will score and the padres take
his 7-nothing lead trevor storey's
having a tough night defensively
and that one just gets through him
darvish scores
seven nothing padres
tough to watch if you're bud black yeah
i think the other play he made the
backhand it was ruled a hit
should have been an error that most
definitely an error
one out in the seventh and garrett
hampson coming up
there's a ground ball down to third
machado the second for one on the first
got him on the tag but the problem is
they don't have a challenge right they
used it earlier in the game
two outs in the ninth inning and here is
ryan mcmahon
ground ball left side
mateo to first that's the ball game
a one two three ninth inning chris matt
retires all six that he faces in the
padres win it 7-0 they shut out the
rocks in game one of the series